c'était en 1992 la création du premier
jeu vidéo québécois têtards depuis plus
d'une quinzaine d'années le québec est
devenu un centre important de production
de jeux vidéo de calibre international
avec de grosses productions comme
assassin's creed ou encore spider man
mais à côté de poids lourds comme
ubisoft par exemple on trouve de plus en
plus de petits studios qui tirent leur
épingle du jeu par exemple hornbein
c'est une boîte de montréal qui vient de
signer une entente avec une star
internationale en vue de la sortie d'un
jeu cet été vont sans mathieu pour cela
d'avoir quelques chiffres en commençant
par ce que c'est une très grosse
industrie ce n'est du tri culturel qui a
du poids on regarde les chiffres
imaginer au canada le jeu vidéo
représente 2.3 milliards de revenus au
québec seulement ses 750 millions et
quand on va en termes d'emplois ces
seize mille cinq cent au canada
9000 au québec seulement c'est dire que
le québec est un des pôles majeurs parmi
les trois qui au canada en ontario et en
colombie-britannique également conclu
une sur représentation du québec c'est
une bonne chose en tout cas pour
l'industrie du ciment est une bonne
chose il ya déjà des studios comme celui
d'arthur mène justement il ya des très
beaux petits studios donc les gros
studios en fait ce que ça fait c'est
qu'il ya des créateurs
las de ces espèces de travail à la
chaîne de travailler sur des choses qui
sont un peu trop sur spécialisés
on veut un peu plus de liberté on se
lance dans les petits studios ssl
l'histoire d'otto ullman est fondée en
2014 en novembre 2014
six mois seulement ils sont faits ils
ont fait un game jam et qui était
commanditée par une des stars mondiales
du jeu vidéo cette star lacets più di
pike les 36 millions d'abonnés si on a
déjà parlé sur youtube six millions sur
facebook et ils offrent ils ont fait un
petit jeu donc un prototype que ni pai a
tellement aimé ça qui les a contactés
surtout été dicté les gueux moi je veux
collaborer avec vous à la création de ce
jeu vidéo là je faire que je jouais ma
communauté collaboration alors les gars
en fait mais oui mais c'est
extraordinaire c'est un peu l'équivalent
dans le monde du roman si oprah winfrey
aux états unis
adoube quelqu'un dit ok moi je vais
travailler avec toi pour faire la
promotion de son prochain roman
c'est pas rien mais ils ont déjà un jeu
de lancer ta potable qui fonctionne très
bien il ya un lien avec le premier jeu
vidéo d'histoire du québec parce que ça
fait référence à un têtard imaginer le
jeu était lancée et seulement deux
semaines déjà 425 mille téléchargements
c'est dire que les pronostics sont bons
pour ce jeu sur lequel il travaille est
vide a requis un peu rétro exactement
c'est un look rétro et c'est aussi
caractéristique du jeu du indy gaming
c'est qu'on veut retrouver un espèce
d'une espèce des sens du jeu vidéo tel
qu'on l'avait dans les années 80 donc on
laisse les grosses productions hyper
léchée et on veut profiter du fait que
donc cet été il y aura un pic comme il
ya toujours à tous les étés depuis 10
passes et un public jeune un public qui
voit et on va profiter donc de ce pic de
trafic sur le site de pully paille pour
lancer ce jeu là d'ailleurs le jeu
portera le nom depuis des pailles plus
d'appareils legend of the blow fister ça
c'est en référence au geste qu'il fait à
chaque fin de vidéo clip fait un geste
comme ça et donc le jeu s'appellera
legend of the blow fist lancé cet été
est ce que ce sera le succès planétaire
on le souhaite en tout cas une chose est
sûre c'est que ça va sûrement rejaillir
sur l'industrie du jeu vidéo au québec
et ça c'est une très très bonne nouvelle
pour ce qui se passe ici parce que le
fait de très très bons jeux apprécié
partout dans le monde alors on
surveillera la sortie c'est marrant